j'ai tellement d'idées pour utiliser ce
truc mais vraiment la journée j'en ai
mais mais un million un million sauf que
tout seul c'est un peu galère et que
j'ai personne moi j'ai pas d'assistant
de machin si seulement j'avais un
assistant
[Musique]
et salut à tous les amis c'est françois
et victor salue la chaîne explique moi
encore une chaîne où on parle de vidéos
de d'image de captation de montage tout
ça et aujourd'hui on a décidé de vous
faire une vidéo de ouf
avec cet objet aulas qui est le lanoye
24 mm macro qui est une pure tuerie
alors on va pas rentrer en fait dans les
détails techniques il ya des review il
ya plein de choses on vous met des liens
dans la description il ya stéphane
couchoux qui a fait une super vidéo là
dessus il ya romain de take me out est
aussi qui a fait un super truc
bref on va pas refaire la même chose par
contre on a eu envie de s'amuser et de
montrer ce qu'on peut faire
[Musique]
il ya tout
m
[Musique]
ouais
millon guilhamat bo est le meilleur
arrière sam ça
[Musique]
m
à
[Musique]
et
un stylet cette jolie s'était pas arrêté
de faire toute la vidéo c'était c'était
quand même cool c'est hyper contraire il
faut savoir quand même que cette optique
là elle ouvre à f 14 ans maximum au
maximum c'est ça dont qu'elle a une
toute petite ouverture donc il faut
énormément de lumière soit vous avez vu
on a les spots on allait les pavots
light plus quand on élève 14 zones de
mettet les méga fine donc on est monté
jusqu'à f40 et on a été jusqu'à f40 pour
ça qu'il ya des led au bout en fait pour
vraiment si on manque de lumière pour
aller dans des zones inexplorées des
territoires vierges
que dire il ya des led au bout pour
ramener un peu plus de lumière en fête a
donc c'était pas évident on a passé tout
l'après midi à faire ces petits bouts là
mais c'était vraiment cool franchement
j'ai manqué puis je vais dire un grand
merci à victor de m'avoir aidé à
réaliser cette vidéo 8 ans il a une
chaîne youtube qui s'appelle victor
bodart simplement avec un lien dans la
description pouvait aller vous abonner
en masse à victor parce que c'est un mec
super sympa c'est ce que tu sais ce que
je dis à la fin est ce que tu connais
alors ya le coût de gloucester et a le
coup de blaster moi je fais et je coupe
le son donc le coût de blaster qui se
situe juste en dessous de cette vidéo
pouvez également vous abonner si c'est
pas le cas activer la clause mettre des
commentaires pour me dire dans quel
endroit vous aimeriez qu'on mette cet
objectif je vous vois venir tous mais
non ne n'y pensais même pas ce n'est
même pas la peine non on oublie puis moi
je vous dis les amis rester curieux et à
très bientôt pour une prochaine vidéo
resté seul dans mon coin c'est et encore
on était sauf
on n'a pas tout montrer le passage avec
le cochon d'inde on ne montrera pas on
n'ira pas jusque là on va le garder paul
dardé pour envoyer des métiers des
commentaires et tout ça si vous voulez
voir le passage avec le cos cabinet
moujik au chemin de croix y avait pas de
cochon n'y a aucun animal n'a été
maltraité en blog voilà